a smaller subsystem if we had the
ability to analyze this we could find a
smaller subsystem which is the pilot you
know this human being who's sitting at
the controls who's actually the the
agent right and maybe you could shrink
it down a bit further and say it's
really just all his his brain it's
everything inside of his skull that's
kind of doing the planning but then we
realize that agency actually has the two
sides of the coin like it has the
planning side of the coin which is only
happening up in here but the inaction
side is perhaps different because if
you're looking at the all the Machinery
necessary to enact the plan it's the
Pilot's brain and the Pilot's body and
the ship itself and all its components
so I think you you know you can come up
with a different boundary if you look at
the inactive piece of agency versus the
planning piece of agency but I think you
do need to on the planning side you need
to at least shrink it down to that
minimal system that contains the the
actual planning that's why I pause with